For our first training machine example,
I've chosen one that tests the oddness
of a binary representation
of a natural number.
Note that I've cheated here
in the transition function
by including only state symbol
pairs in the domain that we
would actually encounter
during computation.
By convention,
if no transition is specified for
the current state symbol pair, then the
program just halts in a reject state.
One convenient way to represent
the transition function by the way,
is with a state diagram.
Similar to what is often used for
a finite automata,
for those familiar with
that model of computation.
Each state gets its own
vertex in a multigraph, and
every row of the transition
table is represented as an edge.
The edge gets labeled with the remaining
information besides the two states.
That is it gets the symbol
red followed by an arrow,
then the symbol to right, and
the direction to move the head.
Now let's trace through the operation of
this Turing machine on this input 1, 0,
1, 1.
The head first reads a 1 from the tape,
and run state q0.
So I go up here and
consult the transition table.
And here,
I see that I should follow this edge,
since that has state q0,
and we read a 1.
And this transition tells me
that I should write a 1 and
leave the tape alone, and
move the head to the right.
And change the state to q0.
So let's go ahead and update our figure.
We're still in state q0,
and the position of the head has
been moved one space to the right.
So this becomes our new configuration.
In the next step, we'll read a 0,
consulting the transition diagram.
We see that this means that we
should leave the 0 alone and
move the head to the right again,
and stay in state q0.
We read a 1 from the tape, and that
means we follow this transition here,
and move the head to the right again.
And the next step is similar.
Finally, the head reads a blank symbol,
the transition table
tells us to write a blank symbol and
move the head to the left.
And to switch the state to q1.
Now, we read the symbol under the head,
that's a 1,
so we follow this transition rule here,
and we end up in an accept state.